carlos consalvi formo parte de la
guerrilla del fmln que se enfrentó al
ejército gubernamental por más de una
década con la llegada de la paz hace 30
años decidió resguardar la memoria de
ese pasado como sustento del futuro del
país que había que construir
y yo rescato de esa gesta de determinar
el conflicto armado como la posibilidad
de soñar un nuevo país y en esa en ese
contexto nosotros creemos que sin
memoria histórica no hay posibilidad de
construcción de mapas de futuro
parte de esa memoria está en el museo de
la palabra y la imagen que fundó
consalvi en
1996 para quien fuera la voz de la
insurgenta de radio venceremos hoy más
que nunca es imperioso este esfuerzo
cuando desde el gobierno se pretende
ignorar la firma de la paz yo creo que
la paz hay que celebrarla hay que
conmemorar la hay que darle el valor que
tiene el diálogo para resolver cualquier
conflicto social
lució vázquez otro de los gestores del
museo sufrió en carne propia el
exterminio de sus seis hermanos y su
madre durante la guerra considera que
hizo falta trabajar por la
reconciliación del país luego del
conflicto que dejó 75 mil muertes y 8
mil desaparecidos
siento que hay muchos que todavía se ven
con ese recelo con ese odio
y las víctimas también quedaron
prácticamente en el abandono la
inconclusa pacificación ha llevado a el
salvador a ser considerado uno de los
países más violentos del mundo sin
embargo estos guardianes de la memoria
siguen luchando por construir la paz
junto a las nuevas generaciones
[Música]